james harden had 21 points
four rebounds and 10 assists in the loss
here he is
very important you know i think we did a
good job of just getting to their bodies
being more
aggressive and then it led to a lot of
opportunities offensively
tim mcmahon james in a game with so much
at stake why did you guys seem so flat
with reporters
that's a good question
to follow up on that how difficult is it
to now have to
not really know why seems so dispirited
for so long
is it frustrating to leave the game
knowing that that was such a big part of
it
i mean there's nothing we could do about
it now but you got to get ready for game
five and
uh bring that same energy had a
carryover into game five
thank you michael shapiro
when you face all those double teams
obviously making that pass is the right
play do you ever
feel an urge to you know force the issue
and try to score a little bit more
uh yeah when the opportunity presents
itself but i mean
you know we go over film we we practice
it
and uh you know we just got to execute
better
mark berman andrew johnson they talk
about asking about being flat what are
some keys to
to avoiding that from the get go
had the same energy we had in the fourth
quarter
thank you james thanks